en medio del desierto de argelia abunda
uno de los productos más codiciados
europa necesita aumentar su suministro
de gas y ha empezado a mirar hacia
argelia y sus 24 billones de metros
cúbicos una de las mayores reservas del
mundo de este combustible fósil
los argelinos saben que su gobierno
tiene las cartas en la mano son bolsos
es algo bueno para el desarrollo de
argelia es una riqueza y vamos a
aprovechar al máximo de esta exposición
tenemos el gas y vamos a usarlo
argelia produce 100 mil millones de
metros cúbicos cada año exporta casi la
mitad los principales importadores son
italia y españa- con gas bombeado a
través de oleoductos turquía importa
cargamentos de gas natural licuado
francia también en 2019 compró
3600 millones de metros cúbicos menos
del 5 por ciento de la producción total
de argelia en su afán por conseguir más
los líderes mundiales se han dirigido
directamente a argelia y con sus sólidos
lazos consiguió un nuevo acuerdo
ya sé ahora que estos suministros
adicionales han sido asegurados por
nuestra vecina italia es incierto que en
el corto plazo argelia pueda producir
suficiente gas para proporcionar más a
la unión europea
argelia podría producir dos veces más
gas de lo que produce actualmente pero
necesitaría mejorar su infraestructura
un proceso caro que podría crear
oportunidades de inversión para francia
pero no es tan simple
aceptado
estos proyectos pueden ser imprevisibles
y arriesgados a nivel económico y
geopolítico y no serían completados
antes de que termine la crisis de gas
yodo existen a racing no la quiero no
hay otra opción alentar a argelia para
desarrollar su energía solar esto puede
reducir su consumo de gas y liberar más
para la exportación cualquier acuerdo
entre argelia y francia dependerá
primero del presidente emmanuel macrón
si logra remendar los lazos después de
un año difícil